[Applause]
really
hello conan first of all congratulations
we've known you a while and
just you just blown up uh recently you
were so nice to me early on and i
i love being here thanks for having me
back congratulations on all your success
uh you were just at the white house
correspondents dinner i was uh this
weekend did you get a chance to meet the
president i
met the president and the first lady it
was crazy
and i actually i got so nervous i had
like 60 seconds
60 seconds six i can't even speak right
now
you're i had 60 seconds with them i
didn't know what to say
i just kept saying thank you like 900
times thank you thank you thank you
and then i hugged michelle obama and i
got really nervous because she's very
fit and i think i hugged her too tight
and i felt her vertebrae and in my head
in my head i was like you can't
you know you can't touch the first
lady's vertebrae like that right right
so you you freaked out a little bit
i freaked out i just said thank you
thank you for letting me touch your
vertebrae and i ran off
you can't do a lot of running around
like that in front of the secret service
it's not good
i know they shot me in the leg
now billy you are known for screaming at
people
and you do it so well i bet you now that
you're becoming famous
people you bump into becoming and they
yes i mean becoming you know you're
almost at
a chair left oh you're an [ __ ]
becoming okay now that you're the most
famous man in america thank you so much
you must be getting people who say oh
please scream at me
yes uh i get a lot of weird tweets from
people not weird you know i love
fans of billy on the street but people
tweet me and they say will you come to
my bar mitzvah and scream at my son
or will you come to my wedding and
scream at my wife
and all these things that i don't want
to do right right so
so you're not going to do any of those
uh i mean i do it for the right price
but you know are you um
you're pretty much in tune with pop
culture you're oh i love pop culture
conan
okay well what about don't you yell at
me i wasn't yelling
i i wasn't yelling that's my normal tone
that's your normal tone yeah
what do you like in a movie theater i'm
just curious
i'm not great
are you sitting there quietly like i
hate this part no i always have to go to
movies with black people who go to see
tyler perry movies because they're so
vocal
you know that's how i fit in that's the
only place i fit in
you're just yelling along i'll say i get
it no i love one of my favorite things
to do is to go see movies tyler perry
movies with an audience full of black
people
because you know they're very vocal you
know and i feel that same way when i'm
watching a movie i'm like you go
madea you know no one says
you go medea i do okay
go she goes to summer camp she goes to
just goes to thanksgiving dinner
700 movies